you talk about how common it is i guess
for comedy to come from tragedy and use
one example of was an elliott schoneman
yahoo reenacted he and his sister
reenacted the ride that cab ride to his
father's suicide so how common is this
and why do we use humor to cover up for
pain okay well it's two different
questions and um we have to bring in the
f-word I'm Freud wrote about three
different forms of humor one of which
was using humor to deal with painful
emotions and it's basically a coping
mechanism we actually did some research
years ago where we looked at the
relationship of death and I'm not hmmm I
wasn't part of that my colleague and I
oh there you go that's better a real
colleague yeah a psychologist the
scholar and I she was a death and dying
expert and we did this study where we
collected a bunch of death jokes and
then non-death jokes and we we gave them
to a bunch of nurses who work around
death in ICU wards and CCU wards and
asked them to rate the jokes and how
funny they were and then we asked their
supervisors how well they cope with the
stress of one of the patients dying and
what we found was that the ones who were
better coping were more able to see the
the humor in these jokes than people who
worked you know in there people who are
really good in stressful situations of
being able to see the humorous side of
something and it's a way to deal with
things to not be so terrible um and
there was a great story that may affect
that Elliott showman told us about home
improvement that they came up with an
idea for a show about cancer
and the network said absolutely not as
know where we're going to have a so they
asked Kemp going and fight for this we
want to do the show and so reluctantly
the network agreed and it got the
highest ratings of any show that they
had that season then the network
compared with right doesn't said could
you write us a few more cancer episodes
do you have any commentary about why
humor is often the flip the drop in the
that it comes from such a dark place a
lot of comedians actually coming from
well I think most most most stand-ups
are pretty unhappy people I think that
the reason for me anyway it's just my
observation is that is that I could take
Hamlet anybody could take Hamlet and
flip it and do it as it as a comedy
would it be any good no but I could do
it I mean they're very close really on
the scale and comedy is much harder to
write because it's much was unless it's
forced comedy is much harder to write so
much harder to be funny you know not not
to try to be funny but to be funny I
just think I think that most thing my
favorite kind of my favorite kind of
writing is I'm gonna mention a writer
who is kind of out of favor but he will
come back as Peter devries who was a
novels a lot of films were made from his
books and he did like dark and light
together and that's my favorite kind of
writing i don't i don't like what in the
business is called balls out comedy very
much i think it's kind of example of
balls out comedy would be some a job
Judd Apatow so early stuff I I like the
grinning big pork east and that wasn't
Judd that was anything that that was you
know real crap that movie he takes
inviting some serious I like um I like a
kind of comedy that's out of fashion now
which is
social comedy that if you look at the
films of the 30s 40s early into the
early 50s even even Billy Wilder's
comedies in the 60s where you know like
the apartment which is a comedy but has
great drama in it you know or the
married couples de Voort like the awful
truth or my favorite wife Renny which
you know are all dark situations but
made light of I think that takes real
skill we don't we don't have that
anymore the closest we got to it in the
last couple of years was bridesmaids
which i think is a terrific movie she is
really a gifted writer Justin wait happy
tune was all over that movie you know he
executive produced it right but it's her
script with what other person and it's
dark it has great darkness in it and so
does this this is 40 and I like social
comedy I like comedy about people I I
love the hangover the first one the
second one was an embarrassment now
they're gonna make a third but the first
one you know the story the history of
that movie is that the studio wanted it
to be 25 year olds they wanted to change
the script they wanted to make it 25
year olds and they wanted just a weekend
in Vegas movie and the writers kept
saying and the producers but the point
is they're about to be 40 and this is
their last hurrah it's not gonna work
you know and then and and it's a I think
it's a wonderful film and it has
something to say about friendship but
about I just don't like comedies I guess
that have absolutely nothing to say
Arthur is my favorite and the original
Arthur not the remake Arthur's my
favorite comedy of the last 25 years 30
years it's more like an old-school
company boy i'm long winded today sorry
about that he got me you got me out of
terror when you get me on things i just
wish we had more varieties or films that
we do i think that's why i like
documentary because you see varieties of
duck that the one you just mentioned has
nothing in common with the film that
there's those two people that made the
boxing movie and the one about the big
studio executive kid stays in the
sure but you get that variety where you
don't get in comedy anymore
you